let's get more on the situation uh on
the ground uh now professor michael
clark our defense and security analyst
is with me michael always good to see
you thanks so much for joining us so
let's uh touch on the the sinking of the
moskva first of all how significant is
it oh it's a big blow to the russians
it's their flagship uh the last time
they lost a flagship within the
russo-japanese war of 1904 so it's a big
prestige blow and that ship was acting
as a uh as the command center it's a
it's a guided missile cruiser and a ship
that uh it does air defense so it would
have been the ship that was actually
organizing the rest of the fleet they've
got about 30 odd ships in the black sea
at the moment so the loss is huge
prestige loss they'll reorganize
themselves but you know there it is
they've got to live with it now and does
it change the likelihood of odessa
getting attacked it's a it's a port town
that we've been discussing a lot well
yeah odessa has been safer for a while
now mainly because the um the ground
forces have not got close enough to a
desk so they got caught at uh mikalayev
and had been pushed back so until odessa
um
until a fleet could get to odessa with
ground forces at the same time uh they
weren't going to achieve very much so i
think that prospect has receded a little
bit odessa today is i would say a bit
safer than it was yesterday i think
we've got another uh map to look at as
well just to talk more broadly about
the black sea fleet as a whole and and
in the sea of ours what are we talking
about in terms of russian forces there
at the moment yes i mean they've got
some pretty big elements in the black
sea of course they've got a very
important port of sevastopol which they
seized when they seized crimea in 2014.
it's illegal but they've got it and
they're using it it's a it's the black
sea port the entry into the black seas
is determined through the strait through
the bosphorus which are controlled by
turkey
and
that's governed by the montreal
convention of 1936 which says that
turkey can can close the straits to
warships if there's a war going on or
they can close the straits to ships uh
that are a threat to them personally and
so there's a big political issue here
you know what will the turks allow
through according to the 1936 convention
what will they not so they've said
they'll allow russian ships to leave the
black sea but they won't let any more go
through and there's there's some quite
big decisions i think coming up because
i think nato are getting to the point
where they think they might want to put
some ships into the black sea in order
to challenge what the russians have been
doing there well that would be a hugely
significant step if we get to that point
and then just sum up for us what we're
looking out for in the the week ahead
particularly as it relates to to the
east and the south and uh when that
likely big russian offensive starts yes
i mean that big offensive is still
building it hasn't really started yet
and the russians are still landing a lot
of stuff at beryansk which is about 50
miles west of mariopol um in order to
move move northwards when that offensive
starts it will be pretty big um we're
seeing lots of fighting going on at the
moment but really the russians are still
building up this big uh concentration of
forces on their side of the border
moving it in as when it starts it will
be quite a big offensive and if we've
got that extra
aid coming from the u.s 800 million
dollars worth
how long does this russian offensive
have to delay for that to be in
ukrainian hands yeah it's a pure guess
but i mean we're talking about a couple
of weeks probably the thing is the
americans are sending the ukrainians
what they can use immediately things
they don't need to be trained on and
they need a lot more ammunition also the
the weather in slavians for the next
week is wet there's going to be rain all
next week that's not good for the
russians it is good for the ukrainians
because it probably buys them a little
bit more time michael as always thanks
so much